sidentin meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren ich bin heilfroh dass wir schon
impfen
wir haben in unserem land bereits über
1,7 millionen erst impfungen
durchgeführt vom erzgebirge bis zur
nordsee im ganzen land das ist gut so
die fdp sagt nun ein gesetz wäre
zwingend auch fotolicht die realität
belehrt sie eines besseren es geht auch
ohne
und es geht eben auch deutlich schneller
die pandemie noch vor dort schnelles
handeln wenn die feuerwehr zu einem
einsatz kommt
da wird zugegriffen und gelöscht und da
werden keine juristischen
spitzfindigkeiten ausgetauscht wir
brauchen keine paragrafenreiter und
schlaumeier wären hinten ort sondern wir
brauchen einen minister der anpackt wir
brauchen ärzte die impfen und wir
brauchen arzneimittel führung die
impfstoffe liefern kollegen raus
gestatten sie eine frage oder bemerkung
vielen dank herr kollege kraus dass sie
mir eine frage gestatten wissen sie ich
bin es wirklich langsam leid dass sie
immer die verfassungsmäßigkeit mit der
schnelligkeit verwechseln
und wenn sie hier sagen dass es nur
daran liegt dass wir schnell handeln
müssen dass wir keine gesetzliche
verfassungsrechtliche grundlage
benötigen und ich frage sie hier ganz
dezidiert wenn die verfassungsrechtler
die professoren ich nenne mal einige
namen die fabio professor team du rhin
professor kießling professor xberg
professor leistender engelsberger
professor da burg alle sagen sie wir
benötigen eine gesetzliche grundlage
und jetzt würde mich mal interessieren
warum sie nicht auf diese experten hören
vielen dank
ich stelle jetzt mal die gegenfrage wenn
sie auf die idee gekommen werden dass es
unbedingt eines gesetzes bedarf warum
sind sie dann nicht schon eher auf die
idee gekommen das zu bringen wir
diskutieren seit oktober seit oktober
wissen wir dass irgendwann mal was
kommen muss dass der impfstoff da als
wir haben darüber diskutiert breit und
das auch richtig in aller öffentlichkeit
wie soll priorisiert werden wenn sie so
klug gewesen wären hätten sie ihren
gesetzentwurf schon dreimal er
einbringen können und ich sage ich mal
ich brauche in meinem wahlkreis nicht
vor den leuten zu treten und erzählt
ihnen von irgendwelchen professoren die
irgendwas wollen die leute sagen game
stoffes darum das muss geimpft werden
und dafür haben wir zu sorgen dass es
möglichst schnell geht und dass es nicht
irgendwelche verzögerungen gibt ich kann
da auch einem kind was zu weihnachten
bot dass es ihr geschenkt bekommt oder
dass es ein geschenk bekommt dann auch
nicht vertrösten und sagen du kriegst
das mal im januar wir müssen
irgendwelche rechtlichen fragen noch
klären das geht nicht
deswegen müssen wir jetzt einfach auch
mal zugreifen anpacken nicht
irgendwelche paragrafen reiterei
betreiben dieser form sondern wirklich
handeln aber meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren bei all den strittigen themen
glaube ich kann man ja auch noch sagen
dass wir in manchen themen ja auch einer
meinung sind nämlich wenn es um den
inhalt dann geht ob man das in ordnung
macht oder um ein gesetz sagt man mit
einer ausnahme abgesehen
und zwar dass wir gesagt ja wir
priorisieren dass diejenigen die den
größten schaden zu erwarten hätten von
der erkrankung zuerst geimpft werden
also die über 80-jährigen das
pflegepersonal auf den intensivstationen
personen mit trisomie 21 bewohnern den
altenheimen
das finde ich gut dass wir das zu machen
weil das auch in anderen ländern anders
gehandhabt wird
die möglichkeit schnell nachzusteuern
haben wir natürlich mit einer verordnung
die ständige impfkommission hat ja zum
beispiel empfohlen das im einzelfall der
arzt entscheiden soll ob junge leute mit
vorerkrankungen vorzuziehen sind und das
ist auch ein guter ansatz das zu machen
das ministerium kann jetzt schnell
reagieren über die verordnung hätten wir
eine regelung
das gesetz in stein gemeißelt dann wäre
eine änderung wesentlich länger und
komplizierter gewesen
keine frage wir sind beim impfen noch
nicht so schnell wie wir uns das alle
wünschen wir wollen dass mehr geimpft
wird das mehr impfstoff zur verfügung
steht
die impfbereitschaft der menschen wächst
rasant seit mitte dezember von 52% jetzt
auf 63 prozent und ich bin sehr
zuversichtlich dass das weiter anhalten
wird weil die menschen erkennen wie
wichtig es ist sich selbst zu schützen
damit wir als land gut durch diese
pandemie kommen und dass wir möglichst
schnell zum normalen leben zurückkehren
können trotz aller lieferprobleme der
hersteller
es gibt mehr und mehr impfstoffe wir
haben zwar noch harte wochen vor uns
aber ich glaube wir sind auf einem guten
weg ich will das deutlich macht man ein
paar beispielen wir hatten gestern die
nachricht dass eine weitere
produktionsstätte für den impfstoff von
bei und tag in marburg genehmigt worden
ist da steht also dann mehr kapazität
zur verfügung wir erwarten heute die
zulassung des impfstoffs von astrazeneca
und ich bin sehr zuversichtlich dass
johnson & johnson deren impfstoff im
abschluss der phase 3 ist der prüfung
also das ist sehr schnell dann auch zur
genehmigung kommen kann
die firma hat ja auch das mutations
virus schon im test mit auch das ist
positiv und wenn dort die zulassung
kommt dann kann es vielleicht gelingen
dass wir am ersten quartal auch mit
dieser impfung beginnen und die
besonderheit bei den impfstoffen johnson
& johnson ist ja dass meine dass eine
einmalgabe ist also man nur einmal
geimpft werden muss
auch das wird uns helfen weil man dann
auch schneller an die hausarztpraxen
kommt und dort impfen kann meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren wir brauchen
macher wir brauchen leute die anpacken
wir brauchen keine parade
deswegen werden wir den antrag der fdp
ablehnen vielen dank sagt alexander
krauß gewesen denn es wird auf grundlage
eines gesetzentwurfs der fdp hier
diskutiert die fdp will die korona
impfung gesetzlich regeln nicht nur auf
grundlage einer verarschung wollen
übrigens auch grüne und linke hier im
parlament dazu werden wir nachher noch
etwas hören jetzt für die position
man spricht jörg schneider sagen wir
können diese im freien folge nicht per
verordnung regeln wir brauchen dafür
eingesetzt daher der vorschlag der fdp
aber ich möchte zunächst einmal auf das
eingehen auf das angeben was sie eben
erzählt haben verkaufs ich habe mir den
vergangenen wochen einige impfzentren in
nordrhein-westfalen angeguckt
vorweggenommen dort wurden gute arbeit
geleistet die waren am 15 zwölfter
arbeitsfähig aber was in den letzten
tagen passiert ist war eine katastrophe
die anmeldungen die anmeldeinformationen
wurden an die betroffene pro gruppe 1
ziemlich zeitgleich verwendet das sendet
und zwar deutlich bevor die anmelde
software scharf geschaltet war damals so
leute versucht sich anzumelden konnten
das nicht die werden schon frustriert
aufgegeben haben bevor dann am montag
endlich diese anmelde software verfügbar
war und dann erlebten die das dann zu
diesem zeitpunkt versuchten die nächste
überraschung weil eben halt alle
gleichzeitig sich anmelden wollten gab
es dort wieder zu abstürzen zu
merkwürdigen fehlermeldung man da man
nenne ich frage mich schon warum kann
ich nicht erst so eine software
freischalten dann die briefe versenden
das vielleicht noch zeitlich gestaffelt
das versteht doch kein mensch was sie da
gemacht haben und vielleicht noch ein
hinweis wir wissen seit dem sommer dass
es zwei impfungen erfordert um immunität
zu erreichen allerdings denkt dass die
anmelde software nicht ab ich kann mich
da auch nur einmal anmelden und dann
kommen die leute in das impfzentrum das
impfzentrum kann nicht mals feststellen
das schon eine zweite anmeldung gibt wir
müssen dann diesen 80 jährigen mit
vielleicht auch gewissen erinnerungs
problem dann fragen haben sie eigentlich
schon zweiter termin
meine damen und herren das ist doch eine
katastrophe und dass die fdp sich nun da
so ein bisschen hinter
verfassungsrechtlichen problemen
verständnis mir natürlich auch klar
denn für das chaos in
nordrhein-westfalen tragen sie dort als
mit regierungspartei eine gehörige mit
waren sport und meine damen und herren
im priorisierung hat übrigens auch sehr
viel zu tun mit eigenschaften des
impfstoffs wir wissen derzeit
eingesetzten stoffe erzeugt eine gute
immunität wir wissen aber noch nicht ob
er auch verhindert dass der geimpfte das
virus übertragen kann wenn wir das
irgendwann mal wissen oder einen eigenen
sohn geeigneten impfstoff haben dann
würde das eine komplette umkehrung der
priorisierung bedeute dann wäre es
vielleicht gar nicht mehr so sinnvoll
den 70 oder 80 jährigen mit wenigen
sozialen kontakten zu impfen sondern es
wäre dann vielleicht viel sinnvoller die
zu impfen die viele sozialkontakte haben
nicht nur die pflegekräfte sondern
vielleicht auch die kassiererin an der
supermarktkasse dem schaffner im zug
oder den parkettboden
wir haben gerade gestern erfahren der
impfstoff von astrazeneca ist für
menschen höheren alters weniger geeignet
heute gab es eine meldung eines neuen
impfstoffs der vsv patienten weniger
geeignet ist wir werden dort ständig die
im prioritäten ändern müssen wir müssen
dort ständig unter umständen für jeden
eigenen impfstoff einer eigenen
strategie haben was sagt die fdp dazu
naja dann gibt es jedes mal eine
verordnung und die muss dann dem
bundestag abgesegnet werden
meine damen und herren wir haben täglich
neue informationen über corona über die
impfstoffe
da kommt man mit den verordnungen
vielleicht noch hinterher
wir würden uns doch im bundestag mit
nichts anderem mehr beschafften
beschäftigen meine damen und herren mein
fazit
ihr antrag ihrer ihr gesetzentwurf der
mag vielleicht den ein oder anderen
verfassungsjuristen glücklich machen in
der praktischen umsetzung kann er so
überhaupt nicht funktionieren und die
probleme die die menschen tatsächlich
gerade draußen im lande haben die löst
er erst recht nicht ich danke ihnen für
das thema impfen hat viele aspekte wir
warten ja auch alles egal ist jetzt
schon mehrfach angesprochen worden heute
auf die zulassung eigentlich der
europäischen arzneimittelbehörde für den
impfstoff von astra 10 egal wir haben
gerade gesehene nachrichtenagenturen ist
zumindest die pk der europäischen
arzneimittelbehörde auf 16 und 30
verschoben worden
aber wie gesagt man rechnet eigentlich
mit einer zulassung heute dieses
impfstoffs
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren so ein e-mail-postfach
von uns bundestagsabgeordneten ist
eigentlich immer ein ganz guter
gradmesser in sachen was bewegt die
menschen im land gerade besonders und da
kann ich ihnen aus meinen zuschriften
eines ganz klar sagen die frage ob wir
die priorisierung der impfung gegen
korona besser in einem gesetz statt in
einer verordnung regeln sollen gehört da
tauchen dort definitiv nicht auf bei mir
ist keine einzige e mail dazu
eingegangen ich kann mir nicht wirklich
vorstellen dass ihre postfächer mit
dieser frage liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von fdp fraktion überlaufen
die menschen in meiner heimat in meinem
wahlkreis möchten antworten zu folgenden
fragen warum klappt das mit der
impfstoff beschaffung nicht so richtig
welche wirtschaftshilfen braucht mein
unternehmen warum klappt das mit der
kurzarbeit zurück das sind die dinge die
menschen bei mir zuhause interessieren
die fragen nicht nicht nach einer krone
virus und gesetz ordnung und so die welt
stehen wir das volk wird die liebert
ihren themen
dieses thema ist ganz besonders eines
was an der lebensrealität der menschen
der probleme die die menschen gerade
haben völlig vorbeigeht
und ich finde wir als parlamentarierin
sollten uns ordentlich mit anderen
fragen beschäftigen und diese debatte
die wir uns auch schon im november
geführt haben gehört irgendwie nicht
dazu sondern schwächt das parlament als
solches vier abgeordnete haben sehr wohl
ein gespür dafür wann und wie wir
reagieren müssen
der bundestag ist auch hier kein
abgehobenes raumschiff auch wenn uns der
eine oder die andere das mal bewerten
das zeigt diese woche zum beispiel sehr
gutes wurde vereinbart dass wir eine
sitzung zu auch aus dem märz bereits in
den beginn des februars vorziehen damit
wir hier gemeinsam debattieren können
hier gemeinsam entscheidungen fällen
können und nicht erst am 22
februar zurück nach berlin anreisen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von der
fdp ich verstehe ehrlich gesagt ihren
grundgedanken bei diesem gesetzentwurf
nicht ganz
können sie so sehen es ist alles gut
wieso soll der selbst gesetzgeber also
der bundestag die im freien folge zum
beispiel festlegen
wir haben da experten zum beispiel vom
robert-koch-institut von der ständigen
impfkommission vom deutschen musikrat
von der nationalen akademie der
wissenschaften leopoldina
dort sitzen eben jene expertinnen und
experten für genau diese fragen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen als sie jetzt
gesetzgeber mit dem dritten
bevölkerungsschutz gesetz in § 20 absatz
3 des sozialgesetzbuch festgelegt haben
welche personengruppen bei den info
gegen saas kaufte zwei grundsätzlich den
vorrang haben und damit haben wir in
diesem korridor schon gesetzgeberisch
ganz klar vorgeschrieben und waren
dementsprechend auch bei der
priorisierung bereits beteiligt und wir
haben festgelegt dass das
bundesministerium für gesundheit die
details dazu in einer verordnung pinkelt
diese wiederum basiert natürlich auf die
neuesten wissenschaftlichen
epidemiologischen erkenntnisse geben
sowie ethischen überlegungen
der vorteil dieser geltenden in ordnung
ist dass mit ihr eben sehr recht
flexibel reagiert werden kann und warum
ist das nötig wir haben einfach eine
sehr dynamische situation das sehen wir
doch hier alle gemeinsam jeden einzelnen
tag ich sage nur impfstoffhersteller und
zugesagte mengen an lieferungen oder
jetzt eben die schon angesprochene
entwicklung rund um astrazeneca hat sich
nach der zulassung durch die emea
herausstellen sollte dass eben dieser
über 65-jährigen mitbürgerinnen und
mitbürger nicht mit diesem vakzin
geimpft werden können dann müssen wir
dann könnten wir ebenso verordnung an
der stelle sehr schnell anpassen und mit
ihrem gesetz gegen das nicht so einfach
und so schnell sehr geehrte damen und
herren die als spd sind davon überzeugt
dass das von ihnen vorgeschlagene corona
im gesetz zur festlegung der
priorisierung diesem regen
infektionsgeschehen überhaupt nicht
gerecht werden kann
wir müssen die notwendigen dynamischen
grundrechtsschutz ausreichend absichern
und das geht
am besten über den weg den wir hier
gewählt haben nämlich die verordnung mit
ihr kann schnell und flexibel projekt
jetzt werde mit einem gesetz in meinen
augen nicht und genau das ist schnell
und flexibel reagieren können brauchen
wir doch hier in einer pandemie ein
gesetz finde ich brauchen wir dazu nicht
extra es ist an dieser stelle nicht
notwendig darin hat uns doch auch die
anhörung im gesundheitsausschuss am 13
januar diesen jahres bestätigt dort habe
ich zwar zugegebenermaßen sind wir doch
erst mal zu ihr kollege dort gab es dazu
geben da maßen auch stimmen die ihre
intention eines gesetzentwurfes im
grundsatz unterstützen
aber eben auch genügend andere
sachverständige haben ganz ganz klar zum
ausdruck gebracht dass ein effektiver
grundrechtsschutz besser über den
verordnungsweg zu gewährleisten ist die
verfassungsrechtler sind sich anders als
sie das hier vermutlich gleich wieder
behaupten werden eben nicht darüber
einig dass priorisierung 's regelung
zwingend durch gesetz zu treffen sind
zum beispiel die sachverständigen
professor und doktor license berger hat
klar und gut begründet für eine
funktions teilung zwischen legislative
also dem bundestag und der exekutive
also der bundesregierung
und sie hat ausgeführt dass ich mit dem
kroner ins gesetz wie es die fdp heute
beschließen möchte kein dynamischer
grundrechtsschutz und diesen verlangt
das bundesverfassungsgericht
verwirklichen lässt
an der verfassungsmäßigkeit ihres
gesetzentwurfes gibt es erhebliche
zweifel die auch eben in der anhörung
aufgezeigt wurden folgerichtig lehnen
wir die spd fraktion ihren gesetzentwurf
ab und ich persönlich könnte mir mich
jetzt je nach wieder um die anliegen der
menschen in meinem wahlkreis
und es ist nicht nur ein problem der
schulaufsicht muss ich glaube die
kollegin muss mit ihnen gar nichts zu
tun
kümmern sie sich um ihr wahlkreis sorry
das ist der frau die hat ja eine
übertragung oder eine hilfe und das war
nicht ausgeschaltet wer ist auch dass
uns die volle saal logisch bin ich auf
sendung klar
also schönen nachmittag ihre kolleginnen
und kollegen jetzt interessant ist
glaube ich dass diese sagen es kommt
eine mächtige für die fdp fraktion
christine aschenberg da und auch claudia
roth ist jetzt auf sendung sozusagen die
hat gerade hier die sitzungsleitung
übernommen als bundestagsvizepräsidentin
und obwohl christina jilek war das
interessant auch auf sie gemünzt denn
sie haben ja gerade hier die sitzung
über noch sehr geehrte frau präsident
sind liebe kolleginnen und kollegen also
was geben gerade gesagt wurde also das
ist ja wirklich unglaublich und auch
eben gerade die kollegin sie arbeiten
einfach mit falschbehauptungen ich war
bei der anhörung dabei und die von ihnen
genannte frau professor leisten
regensberger hat eindeutig gesagt dass
es eines gesetzes bedarf um die
verfassungsrechtliche klarheit
darzustellen
sie gesagt wir können uns ja noch mal
die mitschrift anschauen unsere
gesetzesentwurf meine damen und herren
verfolgt das ziel die
verfassungsrechtliche frage der im
priorisierung gesetzlich zu reden warum
weil der von der koalition geschaffene
rechtszustand diese priorisierung über
eine verordnung zu regeln
verfassungswidrig ist und ich finde es
ein skandal wie sie jeder das
verfassungsrecht mit füßen treten unter
kraus sie sagen was da die experten
sagen dass ihnen völlig egal dass es
eine unverschämtheit es geht hier um
grundrechtsschutz und in und auch wenn
sie jetzt behaupten das ging an der
wirklichkeit der menschen vorbei in dem
moment im moment sind wir uns alle einig
dass die risikogruppen zuerst geschützt
werden müssen aber in dem moment wo es
losgeht wer muss danach erst geimpft
werden der polizist oder andere oder die
lehrer da geht es nämlich los und wenn
dann einzelne leute meinen sie müssten
klagen dann werden sie merken dass das
gesetz verfassungswidrig ist und
deswegen betrifft es dem ich auch die
wirklichkeit der menschen in diesem
lande meine damen und herren ich frage
mal ganz speziell die cdu hier das was
sie bei der anhörung geleistet haben das
wäre ja und mehr eine blockadehaltung
als alles andere
sie waren ja nicht in der lage auch nur
einem experten eine frage zur
verfassungsmäßigkeit ihrer verordnung zu
stellen sie haben die ganze zeit um den
heißen brei herumgeredet was ihr auch
klar als weil sie genau wussten sie
kriegen die falschen antworten genau das
macht man wenn man angst vor den
richtigen antworten hat und das muss ich
ihnen vorwerfen
es herrschte nämlich einigkeit dass die
verordnung des bmg zur priorisierung
verfassungswidrig ist so und das ganze
wurde danach noch und das hat mich sehr
aufgeregt vor dem kollegen robert otte
garniert mit einer fake news kampagne wo
gesagt wurde zwei der
der sachverständigen professor kingreen
und professor kießling auf twitter
wurden sie als afc ja und corona leugner
beschimpft weil da modernen dass es
anstandslos und das ist eines
abgeordneten nicht würdig ja er hat sich
danach entschuldigt aber das reicht
nicht meine damen und herren in einer
demokratie und das sind wir hier und da
sollten sich mal alle besinnen meine
damen und herren ist es aufgabe des
parlamentarischen gesetzgebers
staatliches handeln in grundlegenden
bereichen uns vaters ist ja gerade ein
grundlegender grundgesetz bereich durch
förmlich durch solche gesetze zu
legitimieren und alle wesentlichen
entscheidungen selbst hier zu treffen
und meine damen und herren bei der
priorisierung handelt es sich doch
zweifelsfrei um eine wesentliche
grundrechts entscheidung es geht hier um
leben und tod wer zuerst den impfstoff
erhält wenn das keine grundrechts
entscheidung ist dann frage ich mich
sonst an sonst es ist nicht nur die
aufgabe des gesetzgebers es ist die
pflicht des gesetzgebers diese
wesentlichen entscheidungen hier im
deutschen bundestag zu treffen und das
betrifft die menschen vor ort meine
damen und herren
ja auch wir halten die
verordnungsermächtigung des
bundesministeriums für gesundheit für
angebracht warum das wurde schon gesagt
damit schnell gehandelt werden kann wenn
es erforderlich ist wir sehen es ja
gerade bei astra zenica aber und jetzt
kommt nach unserem vorschlag ist eine
verordnungsermächtigung nur mit
zustimmung des bundestages möglich meine
damen und herren das ist eben der
unterschied
wir brauchen klageverfahren und damit
rechtssicherheit meine damen und herren
ein begriff der ihn leider abhanden
gekommen ist
ich appelliere an alle kolleginnen und
kollegen hier in diesem hause seien sie
selbstbewusster parlamentarier beenden
sie den jetzigen verfassungswidrigen
zustand und stimmen sie unseren
gesetzentwurf zu herzlichen dank sagt
wieland
das los für die fdp fraktion ja es muss
eine im freien folge festgelegt werden
das wiederum ist überhaupt nicht
strittig weil es eben nicht genug
impfstoff gibt und wenn man im moment
noch wenn man auf die zahlen schaut der
menschen liegen kubik 19 in deutschland
geimpft sind die wächst wenn auch
langsam 1,8 millionen bundesbürger sind
erst gift also mit der ersten dosis und
415.000 haben die zweite impfdosis
bislang bekommen
das ist der stand heute kolleginnen und
kollegen die fdp hat hier die arbeit der
bundesregierung gemacht soviel kann man
schon mal feststellen
sie hat eine gesetzliche regelung für
einen massiven grundrechtseingriff
vorgelegt denn vergessen wir nicht
darüber zu entscheiden wer das knappe
gut corona impfstoff zuerst erhalten
darf hebt die gleichheit der bürgerinnen
und bürger auf und schafft vorrang und
nach rang eine gesetzliche regelung also
eine parlamentarische regelung ist
notwendig und ich bemängele mit
nachdruck dass die große koalition bis
heute ablehnt diese verantwortung zu
übernehmen
ich finde es gut dass minister sparen
ein insel eine impfpflicht ausschließt
aber auf der anderen seite gibt es für
die allermeisten keine möglichkeit sich
für eine impfung zu entscheiden und
schon gar nicht für einen bestimmten
impfstoff meine damen und herren wir
können als linke dem gesetzentwurf der
fdp trotzdem nicht zu stemmen
denn und das sieht man hier deutlich es
reicht nicht einfach nur ein gesetz
vorzulegen
es kommt natürlich auf die inhalte an
und da hakt es extrem viele besonders zu
schützenden gruppen mit einem hohen
infektionsrisiko werden in einem
gesetzesvorschlag nicht zur genüge
berücksichtigt ich möchte beispielhaft
die pflegenden angehörigen nennen wir
können auch über geflüchtete
massenunterkünften reden oder prekär
beschäftigte in schlachthöfen oder
anderswo der schutz leben der
angehörigen die in dieser partie nie
vergessen ignoriert und übergangen
werden ist überfällig und da spreche ich
ausdrücklich nicht nur über
impfstrategien wer pflegende angehörige
schützt schützt mittelbar auch die
menschen mit pflegebedarf und im
endeffekt die versorgung in gesundheit
und pflege
die momentan fast kollabiert wir dürfen
nicht vergessen dass die meisten
menschen mit pflegebedarf zu hause und
alleine von ihren angehörigen gepflegt
werden zum größten teil von frauen die
für diese pflege ihre lohnarbeit und
ihre sozialkontakte einschränken
diese große gruppe von menschen immer
wieder soweit nach hinten anzustellen
ist auch aus gründen der öffentlichen
gesundheitsvorsorge veit und wenn sie
mich fragen es ist auch moralisch falsch
lassen sie mich zum schluss noch
folgendes betonen wenn der über eine
reihenfolge reden wer zuerst mit
impfstoff versorgt werden muss ist der
nationale
viel zu eng gefasst die reden über eine
weltumspannende pandemie über eine
gewichtung in der impfstoff vergabe zu
reden ohne über eine freigabe der
lizenzen zu sprechen ist auch allerdings
auch scheinheilig
auch die ernsten ärmsten länder müssen
eine schaffen sie haben meine meine
damen und herren die globale die globale
pandemie überwinden das können wir nur
durch internationale solidarität vielen
bildern pia zimmermann
herr zimmermann war das für jeden linke
grundsätzlich ist die linke auch für
eine gesetzliche festlegung der imf
reihenfolge durch den bundestag aber dem
gesetzentwurf der fdp beginnen und das
haben sie 14 x gerade gegründet hat ihre
fraktion noch zustimmen jetzt werden wir
für die grüne fraktion manuela rottmann
sie ist jetzt als nächstes am rednerpult
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir sind uns mit der fdp
fraktion und da teile ich ihre
wahrnehmung der anhörung mit allen
sachverständigen einig dass die
derzeitige verordnung über keine
gesetzliche grundlage verfügt es geht
hier nicht umgesetzt oder verordnung
jede verordnung braucht eine gesetzliche
grundlage und an der fehlt ist und so
lange dass der impfstoff knapp ist wird
seine verteilung natürlich
konfliktpotenzial ja es gibt bereits
klagen auf impfungen und gegen diese
verordnung und jedes verwaltungsgericht
in deutschland kann diese verordnung
außer kraft setzen
es ist unsere aufgabe als gesetzgeber
solche wesentlichen fragen zu
entscheiden und vermeidbare konflikte
nicht in kommunen oder den gerichten vor
die tür zu kehren erst recht nicht wenn
es um eine so zentrale
die impfung gegen 19 und ich verstehe
nicht warum die koalition dieses völlig
unnötige risiko eingeht dass der
impfstoff nicht eu-weit oder wie es
eigentlich nötig wäre weltweit sofort
verfügbar ist kurz nach dazu lassen ich
finde das muss jedem vernünftigen
menschen vorher klar gewesen sein
aber in dieser schwierigen situation nun
auch noch zu riskieren dass gegen die
regelung für die verteilung gekippt
werden wenn das passiert dann fragen sie
allein sie von union und spd dafür die
verantwortung
der gesetzentwurf der fdp zeigt aber
auch die schwierigkeit gesetzliche
bestimmte regelungen zu fassen in einer
extrem dynamischen lage und wir finden
es ist ihnen nicht gut gelungen das
richtige maß an gesetzgeberische
bestimmtheit und nötiger flexibilität zu
treffen
auf der einen seite gibt es da den
paragrafen 3 der geradezu
detailversessen die im freien folge
durch regulieren will und auf der
anderen seite erteilen sie dann aber in
§ 6 eine verordnungsermächtigung die
diese detaillierte regelung paragraf
treiben der völlig zur disposition
stellt und ich finde die
verordnungsermächtigung der fdp l damit
sehr stark mit ausnahme der beteiligung
des bundestags den anderen
ermächtigungen § 5
infektionsschutzgesetz an deren
bestimmtheit für höchste
verfassungsrechtliche zweifel haben
wir wissen seit gestern dass der astra
wenig impfstoff nur eine zulassung für
erwachsene unter 65 jahren erhalten wird
dh dass nach ihrem gesetz ihre durch
formulierte reinform in § 3 1 stimmte
hinfällig ist und deswegen finden wir
mit ihrem entwurf ist gegenüber dem
status quo zu wenig gewonnen dennoch die
fdp hat sich verdienste erworben weil
sie das thema auf die tagesordnung
gesetzt hat
wir haben einen an
vor spott eingebracht wir wollen zum
einen zum beispiel die belange von
menschen mit behinderungen stärker
einbeziehen die belange und auch die
perspektive der
antidiskriminierungsstelle
miteinbeziehen wir wollen dass die
impfung von pflegenden angehörigen höher
gewichtet wird als bisher um diesen zu
ersparen dass sie in die eigene
isolation monatelangen müssen wir
schlagen aber vor dass wir die im freien
folge nach den groben gesetzlichen
maßgaben die wir machen dem auf dem
verordnungsweg verweisen schreiben
allerdings auch eine beteiligung von
bundestag und bundesrat fest und wir
glauben wir genügen so den anforderungen
von artikeln 80 grundgesetz wir bitten
daher alle um zustimmung zu unserem
antrag es ist auch in ihrem interesse im
interesse der koalition
[Applaus]
manuela rottmann hat angedeutet sich
sozusagen auf den gesetzentwurf der fdp
aufgedeckt und ein änderungsantrag
eingebracht mit denen von ihr hier
die kommen zum beispiel der aktion im
freien folge zumindest mit beteiligung
von bundestag und bundesrat hier
stattfinden soll und auch die belange
von pflegenden angehörigen
beispielsweise an das berücksichtigt
werden sollen darüber würden also auch
gleich bei der anhörung im
gesundheitsausschuss war ich auch dabei
und habe glaube ich auch aufmerksam
zugehört es gab sehr viele meinungen wie
das bei anhörungen immer der fall ist
und meine wahrnehmung
war man kann das machen
man muss es aber nicht machen und ich
bin der meinung wir sollten bei dem was
wir beschlossen haben bleiben die
verordnung zur reihenfolge beibehalten
ich werde mich gegen den gesetzentwurf
aussprechen und begründe das auch gern
wir haben die basis dessen was wir jetzt
tun beruht auf dem dritten
bevölkerungsschutz gesetzt das mit
großer großer mehrheit hier im haus
beschlossen worden ist und wir haben mit
diesem dritten bevölkerungsschutz
gesetzt die bundesregierung beauftragt
eine priorisierung verordnung zu
erstellen und haben ihr auch einen
auftrag gegeben wie sie das machen soll
indem sie also zuerst die bullen
nacharbeiten gruppen impfen lässt und
die die sie pflegen und nach diesem
grundsatz ist die verordnung aufgestellt
worden und nach umsetzen der ständigen
impfkommission
es wird meiner wahrnehmung nach auch im
vorliegenden gesetzentwurf der fdp
diese grundsätzliche reihenfolge nicht
in frage gestellt zudem zudem haben die
länder auf basis der verordnung die
möglichkeit hier in begründeten
einzelfällen änderungen vorzunehmen wenn
wir jetzt dem wunsch der fdp folgen und
die geltende verordnung durch eine
gesetzliche regelung der priorisierung
von personengruppen ersetzen
käme es unweigerlich zu neuerlichen
diskussionen über die änderung der
reihenfolge und die menschen würden
nur verunsichert und ich möcht ich
möchte auch mal den hinweis geben wenn
wir an alle menschen in die
priorisierung gruppe eins aufnehmen
dann werden menschen die heute einen
schnellen zugang zu einem impfschutz
haben hinten angestellt das heißt wenn
man jemanden eine bessere stellung gibt
muss man auch die entscheidung treffen
wen man eine schlechtere stellung gibt
und ich denke die zeit ist nicht da um
diese diskussion zu führen gerade auch
in einer zeit wo hoch emotional über
diese dieses impfen und weniger überall
wird hoch emotional über die
schnelligkeit des impfens diskutiert
aber nicht hoch emotional über die im
freien folge die alten nach meiner
wahrnehmung allgemein akzeptiert ist
und wenn ich mir die entwicklungen an
siege bei den impfstoff astrazeneca wo
man heute davon ausgehen kann dass er
moment dass die datenlage es momentan
nicht hergibt das also menschen über 65
damit geimpft werden
das kann sich jeden tag verändern
es ist wahrscheinlich nicht anzuzweifeln
dass auch der impfschutz für ältere da
ist aber die datenlage gibt es heute
nicht her
und wenn wir das alles auf basis eines
gesetzes regeln wollten dann wäre die in
chance vergeben und deshalb
bin ich der festen überzeugung nicht nur
wegen der schnelligkeit und flexibilität
sondern auch weil wir im dritten
bevölkerungs gesetz die standards
gesetzt haben und dass die regierung
sich danach orientiert hat sollten wir
bei der jetzigen regelung bleiben
mit ihnen werden intel war das als
vorsitzender des gesundheitsausschusses
sprache für die cdu csu fraktion die im
freien folge allgemein akzeptiert aber
es gibt auch kritik beispielsweise von
der stiftung patientenschutz die sagt
die schwerst kranke pflegebedürftige und
der körperbehinderte für die lead
drängen auch auf eine hochstufung in
dieser prioritätenliste auch wenn sie
unter 80 jahren sind also es gibt
ausnahmegenehmigungen aber wie gesagt
auch menschen die bisher noch nicht
berücksichtigt werden können fdp hat er
erhebliche schwächen
leider wieder einmal aber ich will ihm 3
denn erstens sie sind viel zu spät
also ja tut mir leid ich kann es ihnen
nicht ersparen
und selbst wenn wir jetzt sagen wir
machen das gesetz wird einen erheblichen
zeitverzug haben das ist nicht das
alleinige argument aber ich glaube der
zweite punkt der zweite punkt ist
tatsächlich die führende scheindebatte
das haben wir nun schon einige vor
rednerinnen vorhergesagt wir haben
wichtigere probleme die menschen
interessiert so ob nicht auch die ein
gesetz oder eine verordnungsermächtigung
erlassen haben die leute interessiert
bekomme ich einen impftermin wie schnell
wird geimpft wie viele menschen werden
geimpft und da geht es letztendlich
nicht um spitzfindigkeiten die man so
oder so sehen kann die debatte ist
sicherlich wichtig aber sie kommt
zu spät liebe frau kollegin aschenberg
dugnus ich schätze sie sehr das wissen
sie ja auch ich schätze sie auch häufig
für ihre service opposition die sie ja
hier vertreten
aber bei der frage
verordnungsermächtigung bin ich wirklich
heilfroh dass wir das gemacht haben
wir haben damit die grundlagen
geschaffen damit wir bereits im dezember
anfangen konnten mit impfungen wir sind
uns alle einig dass geht zu langsam wir
brauchen mehr impfstoff wir brauchen
schneller impfstoff und wir brauchen
insbesondere mehr termine das geimpft
werden kann
das ist das ist ja die scheindebatte
über die die wir hier führt ist ja
gerade die dass sie im grunde das
fordern was wir bereits mit der
verordnung umgesetzt haben wenn sie
wenigstens den gesetzentwurf etwas
fordern würden
dass die reihenfolge anders ist dass die
priorisierung anders ist das was auch
immer erheblich davon abweicht aber das
ist ja nicht der fall
das ist ja die angesprochen wurden diese
verordnungsermächtigung haben wir im
rahmen der parlamentarischen debatten
hier getan hätte lernen sie eine
zwischenfrage eine bemerkung von steffen
jederzeit ärgern dass die zwischenfrage
einen augen ich habe eigentlich nur fast
eine anregung was sie werden aber schon
unser gesetzentwurf ablehnen frage ist
wollen sie ihn vielleicht abspeichern
damit wenn das drama ausbricht das
reihenweise die gerichte die
dazwischenfunken dass sie dann schnell
unseren jetzt entwurf als ihren eigenen
einbringen können um die situation zu
retten planen sie das
wieder wieder erscheinen wird ich halte
in der diskussion überhaupt nichts von
alarmismus und jetzt hier den alarmismus
zu betreiben dass möglicherweise am ende
dieser sehr kontroversen debatte auch
ein gericht darüber entscheidet und
vielleicht zu einem anderen ergebnis
kommen könnte heißt dem ergebnis nicht
dass wir von vornherein immer sagen das
was wir hier im bundestag mehrheitlich
entschieden haben sei falsch
deshalb möchte ich auch noch mal darauf
hinweisen es hat ja christine
aschenberg-dugnus leider auch wieder
gemacht dass hier immer suggeriert wird
als sei die parlamentarische demokratie
in gefahr als hätten wir diese
verordnungsermächtigung den bmw
übertragen ohne gesetzliche grundlage
wir haben im rahmen des dritten
bevölkerungsschutz gesetzes will ich
hier auch noch mal daran erinnern auch
wenn das eine sehr kontroverse
diskussion war mehrheitlich in diesem
hause entschieden so vorzugehen
und da kann man natürlich anderer
meinung sein man kann sich auch ein
bisschen ärgern als service opposition
dass man da keine mehrheit bekommen hat
aber ich glaube es hilft niemanden und
erst recht nicht denjenigen die vor ort
auf einen impftermin warten die schnell
geimpft werden wollen dass wir hier
darüber diskutieren und sie sagen weil
wir keine mehrheit bekommen haben ist
die parlamentarische demokratie in
gefahr
und insofern glaube ich ist uns allen
mehr gedient ist uns allen auch mehr
gedient wenn wir in der debatte bisschen
zurückfahren unaufgeregter auch
debattieren gerne unterschiedliche
auffassung austauschen
aber mir wäre es lieber wenn wir
gemeinsam daran arbeiten dass wir
demnächst sehr sehr zeitnah nicht mehr
über knappheiten sprechen dass wir nicht
mehr über priorisierungen die wir
vornehmen müssen die infolge von
knappheiten sondern dass wir gemeinsam
sein können wir haben schnell
hinbekommen jeder der geimpft werden
will bekommt einen impftermin und da bin
ich sehr sehr hoffnungsfroh bedanke mich
auch für ihre mitarbeit und herzlichen
dank zu diesen debatten